حرب مفتوحه بين الجيش الروسي ومجموعه
فاجنر وموسكو تتهمه بالسعي لحرب اهليه
وتدعو الاعتقاله
قائد فاجنر يرفع درجه التحدي ويعلن ان
قواته مستعده للموت من اجل الاطاحه بقاده
الجيش الروسي
اوكرانيا تقول ان فاجنر والجيش الروسيه
يفترسان بعضهما والولايات المتحده تراقب
الوضع وتتشاور مع الحلفاء
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه قال رئيس بلديه
موسكو سيرجي سوبيانين انه تم اتخاذ
اجراءات امنيه اضافيه في شوارع العاصمه
موسكو وذلك عقب اعلان قائد مجموعه فاجنر
تمردا على قياده الجيش الروسي وكتب
سوبيانين على التيليجرام انه في ضوء
المعلومات التي تم الحصول عليها ثم تاء
انشطه لمكافحه الارهاب جاريه في موسكو
بهدف تعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه
قائد هيئه الاركان الاوامر بانطلاق
الطائرات وضربها القوافل التي تعبر بين
السيارات المدنيه والشاحنات لا يهمه من
سيقتل فهم امض عاما ونصف العام بقتل
مواطنيهم المدنيين المسالمين بدلا من
محاربه العدو واود ان اشكر الطيارين الذين
رفضوا المثول لهذه الاوامر الاجراميه
ملخص وما جرى اصدر قائد هيئه الاركان
الروسيه اوامر بالقضاء على مجموعه فاجنر
بعد مباحثات مع وزير الدفاع
استهدافنا بضربه صاروخيه وبالمروحيه
وبعدها بالمدفعيه في الوقت الراهن عبرنا
الحدود وخرج حرس الحدود لاستقبالنا
وعانقوا مقاتلين والان ندخل الى رستوف
المجندون الذين ارسلتهم وزاره الدفاع
ابتعدوا عن طريقنا فنحن لا نقاتل الاطفال
الاطفال يقتلهم شويجو الذي يرسل جنودا غير
مدربين الى الحرب لقد ارسل لمواجهتنا شبان
بعمر الثامنه عشر وهم بسن اطفالنا
واحفادنا لذلك سنعيدهم لامهاتهم احياء
ولكن سندمر كل من يقف في طريقنا ان حاول
احدهم ذلك نمد يدنا للجميع وسنمضي قدما
حتى النهايه
ردا على تصريحات قائد
اعلن مكتب المدعي العام الروسي ان قائد
سيواجه عقوبه التمرد المسلح وهي السجن حتى
20 عاما ودعا جهاز الامن الفيدرالي في
بيان مقاتل لعدم تنفيذ اوامر بريكوجين
والقيام باعتقاله كما دعى جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي مقاتل ايفنير لعدم ارتكاب اي
اعمال عنيفه ضد الشعب الروسي او اي اخطاء
اخرى لا يمكن اصلاحها جنرال روسيا قال
ايضا انه يجب على قوات فاجنر التوقف عن
التمرد قبل فوات الاوان وفي رد على
تصريحات الروسيه اعلنت قيادات فاجنر انها
ستنفذ اي اوامر لقائد المجموعه وان
الاستخبارات الروسيه لن توقفها
مؤسس فاجنر يافيغيني من طباخ بوتين الى
متمرد عليه
الاتهامات التي القاها ضد القيادات
العسكريه الروسيه جزء من مسلسل الخلافات
الطويله التي تفجرت منذ العام الماضي بين
الطرفين خلال الحرب على اوكرانيا
بانه كان يقاتل النازيين في اوكرانيا
واعتبرها حجه زائفه يستخدمها الرئيس
الروسي مرارا وتكرارا لتبرير الغزو الخلاف
تصاعد الى حد دخول بريكوجين في عداء علني
شديد مع وزير الدفاع سير جيش ريجو واتهمه
بالاخلاق في تقديم الدعم الكافي والذخيره
لقواته شايغو وبيرجع
هرب الان بجبن من رستوف هرب بجبن كالنساء
ليتهرب من الاجابه عن سؤال لماذا قصفت
المروحيات الروسيه عناصرنا
دوريه ذا ايكونوميس البريطانيه سلطت الضوء
في مايو الماضي على تفاصيل بدايه الخلاف
بين موسكو وفاجنر ورات انه نتيجه فشل
الكرملين في انشاء هيكل واضح للقياده في
اوكرانيا وحسب المجله هناك قاده الروس
يسعون لبسط سيطرتهم على المجموعه وهذا ما
قد يفسر تصريحات
اما موقع مجوز الاخباري فنقل عن مصادر
مقربه من الكرملين بان بريجوجن يتطلع الى
السلطه السياسيه
ويحاول السيطره على حزب روسيا العادله
لدرجه ان هناك من يقترح توليه منصب الرئيس
خلفا لبوتين فيما اوعز محللون ان قضيه
المواطن الروسي اليكسي موسكو اليوم الذي
اعتقلته السلطات بسبب صوره مناهضه للحرب
رسمتها ابنته دقت اسفين الخلاف بين
الكرملين ومؤسس فاغنير اذ طلب بريكوجين من
المد العام مراجعه الحكم ضد موسكو اليوف
والسماح لمحامي فاجنر الدفاع عنه
ايا كانت اسباب الخلاف موقف الرئيس الروسي
يرجح كفه شويجو وبعض المحللين يرون ان
بوتين ربما اتخذ قرارا للحد من نفوذ فاجنر
في اوكرانيا
فقد ثقه بوتين بسبب الخسائر الفادحه التي
تكبدتها المجموعه في اوكرانيا
وفي مطلع يونيو الجاري ايد بوتين دعوه من
وزاره الدفاع للمقاتلين المتطوعين في
اوكرانيا لتوقيع عقود مع القياده العسكريه
بالبلاد وهو ما ينظر اليه على نطاق واسع
على انه وسيله لتاكيد سيطره الكريم
من جانبها نفت وزاره دفاع روسيه صحه جميع
الرسائل ومقاطع الفيديو المنشوره من قبل
حول الضربه المزعومه من قبل وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه على المعسكرات الخلفيه لمجموعه
فاجنر قائله انها لا تتوافق مع الواقع
وانها استفزاز يعلمي
مجموعه
شبه عسكريه اثاره الجدل منذ عام 2014
عندما استخدمت هاروسيا في ضمن شبه جزيره
القرم
عن عسكريه اساسيه لموسكو
يعود تاسيسها الى الضابط في المخابرات
وكانت تحارب في ليبيا عام 2016 داعمه قوات
حفتر
وبرز النشاطها العسكري في افريقيا منذ عام
2017 على حساب الوجود الفرنسي لكن تصدر
رسمها العناوين العالميه خلال الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
دارت حول تورط فاجنر بعده انتهاكات
اكد الكرملين ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين يتلقى تقارير متواصله حول تطور
الوضع اثر اعلان مجموعه فاجنر الانتفاض
على قياده الجيش الروسي قال المتحدث باسم
الرئه
ان وزاره الدفاع وجهاز الامن ووزاره
الداخليه والحرس الوطني تبلغ الرئيس بشكل
مستمر الاجراءات المتخذه لتنفيذ التعليمات
التي اعطيت لها
حتى نائب قائد الحمله الروسيه في اوكرانيا
الجنرال
مقاتل جماعه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه على
التخلي عن مقاومتهم للقياده العسكريه
والعوده الى قواعدهم وقال في رساله بثها
عبر تطبيق تيليجرام ان العدو يترقب او
يترقب التدهور الوضع السياسي الداخلي في
روسيا
[موسيقى]
اعلنا الجيش الاوكراني انه يراقب الخلاف
ان الشعب بين فاجنر والقياده العسكريه
الروسيه بعدما اتهم قائد
الجيش الروسي بقتل عدد كبير من عناصره في
قصف استهدف مواقع خلفيه لهم في اوكرانيا
قالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه في تغريده
على تويتر انها تراقب الوضع في حين اعلن
قائد الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
والجيش الروسي بدا يفترسان بعضهما البعض
للحصول على السلطه والمال
واذا تطورات ما بين قائد مجموعه فاجنر
لاداره الروسيه اقل المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي ادم هودتش ان البيت الابيض
يراقب تطورات الوضع في روسيا اثر انتفاضه
مجموعه فاجنر على قياده الجيش الروسي
مشيرا لان الرئيس جو بايدن طلع على ما
يجري هناك ونتشور مستمر مع الحلفاء
والشركاء بشان التطورات في روسيا
قالت الاداره العسكريه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه على التيليجرام انه تم تفعيل
نظام الدفاع الجوي في كييف في وقت تسود
اوكرانيا حاله من التاهب استعدادا لاي
ضربات روسيه هذا وسمع داوي انفجارات قويه
في خركيز بحسب ما اعلن ايغورتريه رئيس
بلديه ثاني مدينه في البلاد
على صعيد اخر تهامه روسيا اوكرانيا
بمحاوله صنع قنبله نوويه قذره جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي اعلن احباط محاوله
اوكرانيه لنقل عبوه تحتوي على ماده مشعه
شديده الخطوره كانت في طريقها لصناعه
قنبله قذره واستخدامها قبل توجيه الصعبه
الاتهام لروسيا
احداث الحرب في اوكرانيا تتسارع يوما بعد
يوم الاصابع لا تتوقف عن الضغط على الزناد
والقصف يستمر بلا هواده الكلام عن القنبله
القذره يتصدر العناوين من جديد موسكو تعلن
احباط محاوله نقل عبوه تحتوي على ماده
مشعه شديده الخطوره كانت في طريقها نحو
اوكرانيا لصناعه قنبله قذره وفق هيئه
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي كافلام الحركه
والتشويق الامن الروسي القى القبض على
خمسه اشخاص كانوا بصدد نقل العبوه الى
خارج البلاد في مقابل مادي تبلغ قيمته
ثلاثه ملايين الف دولار للاضرار بصوره
روسيا بالتنسيق مع شخص اوكراني حسب موسكو
العبوه يصل وزنها الى كيلو جرام واحد
وتحتوي على ماده السيزيوم 137 ماده تستخدم
طبيا في الكشف عن عيوب اشعه جاما وتدخل في
تركيب مجمعات الفحص ومعد القياس والتعقيم
الاشعاعي للمنتجات الغذائيه والادويه وفي
العلاج الاشعاعي للاورام الخبيثه جهاز
الامن الروسي قال ان الماده تمثل احد
النظائر المشعه الرئيسيه المكونه للجرعات
وتنتج عن انشطار اليورانيوم والبلوتونيوم
ما يشكل خطرا كبيرا عندما تدخل جسم
الانسان ماده يمكن استخدامها حشوه لقنبله
قذره وفق خبراء روسيا اتهمت كياف قبل ايام
بتنشيط برامج لصناعه قنبله نوويه قذره من
خلال ارسال دفعه من الوقود المشع من محطه
ريفن وذريه لاعاده معالجته اتهامات تنفيها
اوكرانيا جمله وتفصيلا تطورات تعود بنا
الى فتره سابقه من الحرب كان الحديث
خلالها لا يتوقف عن قنبله قذره وكل طرف
يلحي باللائمه على الاخر بالتخطيط
الاستخدامها بلال الوجدين العربيه
الشاطره مستمره وفيها بعد الف
اصل نجل الملياردير الباكستاني كان مرغوبا
من رحله الغواصه تايتن ولكنه ذهب فقط
لارداء الوالده
اهلا بكم من جديد تجددت الاشتباكات في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
امتدت الى مناطق اخرى من البلاد استخدمت
الطرفان اسلحه خفيفه وثقيله بالاضافه الى
اللجوء الجيش السوداني الى الطائرات
الحربيه وطائرات الاستطلاع تاتي تطورات
على الارض وسط مخاوف دوليه من دخول مناطق
جديده الى المواجهه الداخليه والتي تجاوزت
الشهرين منذ اندلعت
لم تقف الاشتباكات في السودان بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع عند حدود تجددها
فقوتها تصاعدت ورقعتها اتسعد
مدينه الاوبيض عاصمه ولايه شمال كردوفان
شهد التجددا للاشتباكات شملت احيائها
الجنوبيه والغربيه كما شهدت المدينه تصدق
قوات الجيش السوداني لمحاوله قوات الدعم
السريع اقتحام مطار المدينه ومقر القيادات
العامه وفق شهود عيان اما الاشتباكات في
منطقه ام درمان واحيائها فقد وصفت باكثر
الاشتباكات عنفا بعد ان كانت الخرطوم هي
الاقوى فالجيش قصف مواقع القوات الدعم
السريه باسلحه خفيفه وثقيله وصواريخ وسط
تحليق طائرات لسلاح الجو السوداني وفق
بيانه بالمقابل ردت قوات الدعم السريع
بالمضادات الارضيه
وفي غربي الخرطوم يبقى المشهد ماسويا حيث
افادت تقارير ومحليتهم بسماع اصوات
انفجارات بالمنطقه الصناعيه واحياء ارميلا
والحله الجديده بالقرب من سلاحي الذخيره
والمدرعات للجيش السوداني كما وقعت
انفجارات قرب معسكر طيبه التابع للقوات
الدعم السريع جنوبي الخرطوم ولم تغب
دارفور عن التصعيد الحاصل فشهدت مدينه
الفاشر شمال الاقليم ونيال جنوبه اشتباكات
عنيفه اوقعت قتلى وجرحى من المدنيين اما
قساوات المعارك في مدينه كادوغلي عاصمه
ولايه جنوب كردفان فاجبرت السكان على
الفرار من المدينه مع تصاعد التوتر وهو ما
يهدد بفتح جبهه صراع اخرى في الحرب
الدائره بالبلاد وفق رويترز وبالتزامن مع
العنف الدائر في السودان تتكشف مقاس
المدنيين يوميا وسط تحذيرات دوليه من
كارثه انسانيه في البلاد حنان المصري
العربيه
في ظل تراجع نفود باريس في القاره السمراء
وتوسع الوجود العسكري الروسي فيها اتهم
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون روسيا
بمحاوله لزعزعه الاستقرار في افريقيا من
خلال نشاطها العسكري عبر قوات فاجنر الا
ان الكريم
القاره السمراء وبالرغم من الصراعات التي
تعاني منها تحولت مؤخرا لساحه حرب فرنسيه
روسيه على النفوذ في البلاد بعد ان كانت
فرنسا المسيطره لعقود
تصريحات اطلقها الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
افريقيا ماكرون وصف روسيا بالدوله
الاستعماريه الحديثه والتي لا تحترم
القانون الدولي من خلال النشاطها العسكري
في افريقيا وحربها على اوكرانيا ان روسيا
قوه مزعزعه للاستقرار في افريقيا عبر
ميليشيات خاصه تنكل بالمدنيين فالامم
المتحده وثقت ذلك عبر نشاط مجموعه فاجنر
في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
لكن كان له راي اخر نفيا كل الاتهامات
الموجهه له على لسان ديمتري قائلا ان
انشطه روسيا في القاره السمراء لا تستهدف
اي دوله ثالثه ولا ينبغي ان تكون مصدرا
للقلق
حرب النفوذ لم تقتصر على الوجود العسكري
بل ارتقت الى مستوى الاعلام ايضا مقاطع
فيديو انتشرت في افريقيا الوسطى تزعم ان
فرنسا تخطط لتشويه سمعه مجموعه
لتقوم بتنفيذ عمليات واتهام
امر ان فتحه الخارجيه الفرنسيه مؤكده انها
تتبعت مئه حساب تابع لمجموعه فكنور وتحاول
من خلالها تشويه سمعه فرنسا بين
مستعمراتها السابقه وفق وحده لمراقبه
الاعلام في الوزاره
انحسار لنفوذ باريس في مستعمراتها السابقه
خاصه بعد سحب قواتها من مناطق افريقيه عده
على حساب موجه مد روسيه في العمق الافريقي
يثير قلقا عالميا في حال بسطت موسكو يدها
على القاره اذا عمر العربيه
ضغوطا المتزايده بدات تؤرق الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وقد ترهق حملته
الانتخابيه ففحين لم يخرج بعد من اخراج
قضايا ابنه هنتر تاتي احداث المساعي
الجمهوريه لعزله على خلفيه حادثه الحدود
مع المكسيك
صيد في الماء العكر ليس اكثر توصيف ارتبط
بمحاوله الجمهوريين الاخيره لعزل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن فمحاولتهم تصب في خانه
صرف الانتباه عن مسلسل ترامب القضائي اولا
وزياده الضغوط على الرئيس المتهم اساسا
بعدم الاهليه لولايه ثانيه تصويت الذي
قاده اقصى اليمين الجمهوري نجح بانتزاع
219 صوتا مؤيدا في خطوه يؤمل منها فتح
تحقيق لعزل بيض فمشروع القانون يشمل
اتهامات لبايدن بسوء استخدام السلطه
والتقصير في اداء واجباته كرئيس واتهامه
بتسليم السيطره العملياتيه على الحدود
الامريكيه المكسيكيه الى عصابات اجراميه
اجنبيه بسبب سياسته بشان الهجره
تمرير مشروع القانون احرج رئيس مجلس
النواب كيفن مكارسي الذي احاله الى لجنتي
الامن الداخلي والقضاء في محاوله لابطائه
وفي حال تصويت اللجنتين ايجابا يعاد لمجلس
النواب للتصويت عليه علما بان القانون
بحاجه الى اغلبيه ثلثي الاصوات في مجلس
الشيوخ ليصبح نافذا وهي الغرفه التي اعفت
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب من الاقاله
مرتين وفي وقت ينص الدستور الامريكي على
امكانيه عزل الكونجرس للرئيس بتهمه
الخيانه والفساد او جرائم كبرى الا ان
اطلاق اجراء اقاله رسميه يبقى فرضيا جدا
بسبب نقص الدعم السياسي فبقيه المعارضه
الجمهوريه تتخوف من تحويل الاجراء الى
ممارسه محض حزبيه
كما ان شواهد التاريخ الامريكي عن عدم
وجود السوابق لعزل اي رئيس تضع هذه
الاتهامات الاخيره لبايدن باطار صفعه
انتخابيه اخرى فالاخير محرج سياسيا بسبب
قضايا ابنه هانتر ويكافح لاثبات اهليته
عقليا وجسديا
الملياردير الباكستاني شاه زاد داود وابنه
سليمان كانوا من بين خمسه اشخاص لقوا
حتفهم على متن الغواصه في رحلتهم لاستكشاف
حطام السفينه تايتنك يقول اقاربهم ان
نجلاء رجل الاعمال الثري كان مرعوبا من
الرحله وذهب فقط لارضاء والده
هنا انتهت رحلتهم في قلب المحيط الذي
ذهبوا اليه بدافع المغامره ثم لاقوا حتفهم
هناك
الملياردير الباكستاني شهزاد داوود وابنه
سليمان كان من بين خمسه اشخاص على متن
الغواصه
لاستكشاف حطام السفينه الشهيره تايتنك رجل
الاعمال الباكستاني هو نائب رئيس مجلس
اداره شركه انجرو لانتاج الاسمده والاغذيه
والطاقه وكذلك شركه داوود هركليز للصناعات
الكيماويه وفق صحيفه ديلي ميل البريطانيه
اما ابنه سليمان ذو تسعه عشر ربيعا فقد
اخبر افراد اسرته بانه قلق بشان الجوله
ولم يكن مستعدا لها غير انه وافق ارضاء
لوالده للاحتفال بعيد الاب معه وفق عمته
سكان من كراتشي يقولون ان مواطنهم القتيل
في غرق الغواصه نجا في حادث سابق لكنه عاد
وكرر المغامره فلم يعد منها هذه المره
حطام جديد اذا لحق بحطام عمره حوالي 100
عام في اعماق المحيط الاطلسي
وغواصه كانت تحمل افرادا لم يبقى منها سوى
بقايا وحكايا وصور وذكريات
اعلنت الخطوط الحديديه السعوديه عن اكتمال
مراحل تشغيل التجريبيه لقطار المشاعر
المقدسه قبل انطلاق التشغيل الفعلي لموسم
حج هذا العام كما اعلنت عن استكمال مراحل
التجريب والاستعداد التام لبدء تشغيل قطار
المشاعر المقدسه يوم الاحد موافق للخامس
والعشرين من يونيو اذ سينقل الحجاج من
مشعل من الى مشعل عرفات مساء يوم الترويه
اعلنت شركه المياه الوطنيه السعوديه
اكتمال جميع استعداداتها لاداره قطاعيه
المياه والخدمات البيئيه بمكه المكرمه
والمشاعر المقدسه لمواسم الحج اكدت شركه
على جاهزيه الخطه التشغيليه لهذا العام
والتي ركزت على توفير كميات المياه
اللازمه وتوزيعها وضخها الى مكه المكرمه
والمشاعر المقدسه بكميه خزن تشغيل
واستراتيجي تصل الى اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
متر مكعب
في نهايه النشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
حرب مفتوحه بين الجيش الروسي ومجموعه
فاجنر وموسكو تتهمه بالسعر لحرب نهليه
وتدعو الاعتقاله
قائد فاجنر يرفع درجه التحدي ويعلن ان
قواته مستعده للموت من اجل الاطاحه بقاده
الجيش الروسي
اوكرانيا تقول انفاجنر والجيش الروسيه
يفترسان بعضهما والولايات المتحده تراقب
الوضع وتتشاور مع الخلفاء
شكرا لكم على كرم المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات